the 2008 roast
um with bob is one of the all-time
greats i mean it is a moment and a lot
of people were like whoa what is
happening i googled bob saget and it
came back why
we were like okay it was gonna be fun
here we go and for a lot of people it
was a revelation because that was you're
still you're still basking in the glory
of full house yeah and i remember they
asked them but they they said no to it
they wanted at the end for the olsen
twins to come out and both give him the
finger and and that's another funny
thing because he
he was like their father
uh he was very protective of the olds
and twins because
he
he knew them since they were babies
and he was with them every day for years
so
he he saw himself as their father so as
they got older and they were going
through all their craziness and the
paparazzi's following them around he
still felt a sense of responsibility
uh yeah yeah he was he was he cared
about them that's amazing but that tells
you who he is that tells you right there
that he yeah he would do that i'm a
little tired maybe i'll take a nap okay
what are you doing waiting for my hug i
thought that's what you do in this house
when you leave a room
how would you explain who bob was in the
stand-up comedic world what did he mean
to comedians it was funny it's like when
the film the aristocrats came out there
were people saying oh god could you
believe bob saget was so sick and so
filthy and no one who knew him was the
least bit surprised
in fact
when the people who knew him full house
was uh something they'd laugh at
because it's like they'd say no he's not
this uh
wholesome
guy
and it's like whenever i would talk to
him
it's like the conversa if the
conversation ever got in any way
serious or sincere uh both of us would
turn it you know filthy and perverted
and that's the way we felt comfortable
bobbles all those guys that you believed
was going to be around forever it just
doesn't make sense everybody has a great
bob saget story do you have a great
bob's story or a moment you you cherish
or remember the most i remember at at
the screening for the aristocrats the
premiere i was walking down the aisle
and i ran into him and he looked at me
and smiled and said i have to hold you
i always kind of remember that i just
remember so many of those funny moments
like that what do you think bob's legacy
is well he'll be remembered for all the
people who watched him over the years
full house funniest videos
and the people who knew him will
remember him as you know a great guy
really funny really quick
and it was always uh fun you know like i
did his podcast he did mine and it was
always fun and always outrageous and
just easy
[Music]